we also have breaking news about how the
virus is spreading chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook is with us
dr. LaPook what have you learned I just
got off the phone with dr. Anthony Fauci
20 minutes ago he's the head of
infectious diseases for the NIH he told
me there is now clear evidence that a
woman who came from China from Shanghai
to Germany and had no symptoms at the
time transmitted this virus four people
ended up getting infected she didn't get
sick until she was on the plane back to
China now the good thing is that they
had very mild symptoms and this would
never been picked up he said had there
not been this scare it sounds like bad
news in that we will
how can you contain a virus that is
spreading without you seeing it spread
yeah all right so I asked Tony to give
me this this perspective he said
generally epidemics and infections like
the outbreaks are not driven by these
asymptomatic infections and you can look
at it two different ways one as you
absolutely correctly say it makes it
harder to figure out who to follow how
long to follow them from for on the
other hand we're hearing about a
mortality rate of about two to three
percent if it turns out that ten times
that or more are getting infected and
it's very mild we never know about it
then the mortality rate may be 0.2 or
0.1 which is kind of like as he said
it's kind of like a bad flu season so
John what's the significance of the
World Health Organization declaring this
a global health emergency you know I was
on that call yesterday too and then and
what he said was look the main thing
we're after is countries that do not
have robust health care systems you know
in the United States we have it and
there are a lot of lessons we've learned
from the Ebola crisis there were some
missteps there they learn their lessons
and we're right now we're doing basic
infectious disease measures which means
finding somebody who's infected
isolating them figuring out who their
contacts were and then following them
remember right now there's no vaccine in
the near future and there's no
medication that works although they're
trying AIDS medications and some other
drugs I hope they don't have to use that
tent out there in California dr. Jon
LaPook thank you very much we appreciate
it